[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des facteurs de grands prix sont un peu
comme les hirondelles reviennent chaque
année sont les circuits avec le beau
temps ici maurice trintignant sur sa
lotus numéro 12 après le départ du 22e
grand prix de pau
depuis 25 ans le pilote en cl à 44 ans
participe à presque toutes les grandes
épreuves
circuit de pau limoges bonheur
ordinairement
doit avoir du tutorat il a encore bon
pied bon oeil et conduit sa vie et lotus
avec sagesse et virtuosité
ce qui n'est pas le cas de tous les
concurrents on dérape plus bien
longtemps sa mécanique comme l'ancien
champion du monde jack brabham et
lantourne après 204 de moyenne sur un
circuit très accidenté quand il y en a
aucune difficulté à repousser toutes les
attaques même celle de la ferrari numéro
6 de ricardo rodriguez
l'enfant terrible de la course
automobile qui sera sans doute la grande
vedette de 2
dans un palais bourbon dans la façade
disparaît derrière un tamis
d'échafaudages l'assemblée pour écouter
la déclaration du nouveau premier
ministre s'est réuni au grand complet
e
devant l'assemblée présidée par monsieur
chaban delmas monsieur georges pompidou
a exposé le programme de son
gouvernement qui fait une large place au
problème social il faut relever aussi
l'appel au bon sens lancé aux européens
d'algérie et le pas en avant fait aussi
bien sur le plan de l'alliance
atlantique que sur celui de l'europe
unie
[Musique]
par ailleurs en ces mêmes journées
monsieur ap rahman farès président de
l'exécutif provisoire d'algérie s'est
rendu à paris où il a été reçu par le
général de gaulle à sa sortie de
l'elysée monsieur farès assailli par les
journalistes a déclaré que la date du
vote de l'autodétermination et est
d'ores et déjà fixée
[Musique]
à oran qui s'opposent encore en
multipliant des incidents meurtriers à
l'application des accords d'evian de
nombreux renforts ont investi la ville
le commandement militaire a maintenant
sa disposition des forces suffisantes
pour rétablir l'ordre
le bouclage de certains secteurs
névralgiques et des fouilles méthodiques
ont permis de retrouver des documents
importants et des armes
[Musique]
est-ce pour bientôt le retour de la
légalité à oran
[Musique]
autrefois les hôpitaux n'étaient que des
centres d'hébergement relevant du
domaine de la charité est destiné à
recueillir les indigents certains
bâtiments devenus vétustes et
quelquefois sordide créé pour les
malades un abattement de psy chic qui
peut être une véritable hantise pour les
hospitalisés
[Musique]
avec la semaine nationale des hôpitaux
la fédération hospitalière de france
nous permet d'apprécier les efforts
accomplis le malade ne va plus être
seulement un cas pour les statistiques
un client pour les hôpitaux mais un
autre
en rompant avec la politique d'austérité
et la carence du financement qui ont
freiné l'évolution hospitalière
l'hôpital sera est déjà ce qu'il
n'aurait jamais dû cesser d'être un
grand service public au service de votre
santé
[Musique]
notre époque qui est celle de la
technique suscite et rend nécessaire
l'expansion économique sur le territoire
français des fabrications de toute
nature se développe depuis l'industrie
lourde jusqu aux industries alimentaire
c'est ainsi que certaines brasseries
compte aujourd'hui comme des modèles du
genre quant à l'automaticité et son
corollaire la productivité mais de
telles entreprises représentent des
investissements considérables le crédit
national a été créée justement pour
assurer par des prêts une part du
financement et permettre à l'économie
dans les délibérément de l'avant
son action touche tous les secteurs
industriels et commerciaux dans le
domaine encore neuf des produits
chimiques elle a permis la réalisation
de la première fabrique de caoutchouc
synthétique en france
l'économie se doit de regarder vers
l'avenir de le préparer
c'est pourquoi il importe d'investir dès
à présent d'investir largement
[Musique]
roubaix a grandi mais n'a pas changé
mais dans la ville cette jeune main qui
chaque matin arrêté son réveil est
maintenant une vieille me jeanne coque
ouvrière à la redoute à roubaix vient
d'être après 68 ans de service dans la
même maison décorée de la légion
d'honneur
et il est bien qu'une distinction de
cette valeur viennent récompenser tant
d'années au travail depuis le temps où
jeune fille madame jeanne coque figurait
dans le groupe d'une photo aujourd'hui
jauni
[Musique]
aujourd'hui encore chaque matin une
jeune ouvrière vient prendre à sa porte
la vieille ouvrière
ensemble les deux compagnes les deux
époques font le trajet qui les sépare de
la fabrique et le philosophe pourra
trouver dans cette route commune de deux
êtres que c'est par tant d'années de
subtiles et sensible correspondance la
même maison rajeuni bien sûr les mêmes
gestes à l'arrivée
les mêmes gestes au travail dans des
locaux qui depuis 68 ans on s'en doute
bien changer la vie
la légion d'honneur pour une vie de
travail et d'exactitude voilà une légion
d'honneur bien placé
[Musique]
l'ancien régime le nouveau régime et la
formule est valable pour les boissons
comme pour les rythmes
[Musique]
et voici pour cela leurs des souvenirs
parce que nous avons tous d'un sait
quelque chose et l'on peut dire l'âge de
chacun si l'on connaît la danse de son
temps
on en connaît encore qu'il vire à la fin
de la belle époque l'apparition du tango
moustache conquérante et bottines à
boutons
[Musique]
et certaines bouches de métro garde
encore le souvenir de ce fameux bon
temps que rompit la guerre de 14
l'exposition des arts décoratifs avec un
doux merck souriant et des messieurs en
haut-de-forme coïncida avec le temps du
charleston
[Musique]
on vit bâtir la ligne siegfried et la
ligne maginot aux accents du landais
walk qui parti d'un quartier de londres
n'évite à rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
paris connu l'occupation
[Musique]
et c'est dans ce climat que naquit le
swing
[Musique]
l'occupation se termina le temps du
swing aussi mais il lieu de bruyants
séquelles le rock
[Musique]
le cha cha cha succède à oran en
l'accusant de mièvrerie dans une époque
aux crises forcené
[Musique]
puis le twist vingt sept danses
exceptionnelle qui exige un minimum de
place pour un maximum de sensations
[Musique]
mais le twist et il en perte de vitesse
on parle d'une renaissance du tango on a
vu renton il dansait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le tango avec guy béart commence à
compter ses champions
allons-nous rajeunir de 60 ans
[Musique]
alger les étudiants européens ont pris
au marché la place des marchands
musulmans ceux ci comme les ouvriers du
service de nettoiement ont déserté la
ville européenne après l'attentât du
centre d'un bouche des dockers qui fit
62 morts et 110 blessés tous musulmans
[Musique]
ainsi chaque jour mesure-t-on davantage
les graves conséquences de la violence
entretenue par l'ouest ça plus
spectaculaires manifestations ces
derniers jours aura été l'explosion du
camion-citerne piégée dans le quartier
des tagarins les sens la citerne en
contenait 16000 nip propage à l'
incendie tout au long de l'avenue bilan
trois morts et une trentaine de blessés
mais le bilan aurait dû être plus
tragique si comme l'envisageait les
auteurs de l'attentât le camion avait
achevé sa course sur le quartier
musulman dati en contrebas
et la fièvre d'alger s'alimente chaque
jour un peu plus à ces attentats qui
s'aiment systématiquement la terreur est
aussi la reine
jusqu'ici les musulmans n'ont pas
répondu mais ils désertent les hôpitaux
habituel
acclimate france et dans d'autres
quartiers musulmans le fln a installé
ses propres hôpitaux les blessés
musulmans viennent chercher les soins
des médecins musulmans et dit on aussi
de médecins européens
le fossé on le voit n'est peut-être pas
si définitif
[Musique]
amsterdam pour la célébration de leurs
noces d'argent la reine juliana le
prince bernhard ont conduit un cortège
de rois et de prince la reine elizabeth
au bras du chatrier l'impératrice farah
au bras du prince ashwin de l'ip frère
du pain de bernard la princesse beatrix
au bras du roi olav de norvège la grande
duchesse de luxembourg au bras du prince
philip d'edimbourg 4 rennes st croix et
des dizaines de princes et de princesses
qui ont permis aux photographes de
réaliser un très exceptionnel portrait
de famille
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que l'inde qui fut bien
entendu associé à cette fête qui
coïncidait avec la célébration du 53ème
anniversaire de la reine juliana a
célébré à sa manière le 1er mai 1er mai
royal
c'est une espèce de rencontre au sommet
idéal qui a réuni à washington john
glenn celui qui fit trois fois le tour
de la terre et d'hermann titeuf celui
qui le fit 17 fois ils ont considéré en
connaisseur la capsule qui transporta
shepard et se sont racontés bien entendu
des histoires d'astronautes
ensemble ils ont été reçus à la maison
blanche par le président kennedy n'ai
aucune révélation marquante une sortie
de la confrontation des deux cosmonautes
[Musique]
l'opéra de paris des centenaires ou
presque voici juste cent ans que fut
posée la première pierre d'une vingtaine
de projets qui avaient été soumis au
concours et qui proposait des monuments
très différents c'est le projet de
l'architecte charles garnier qui avait
été adoptée à l'unanimité d'ailleurs
garnier devait consacrer 14 ans à sa
réalisation les travaux qui allaient
permettre d'installer l'opéra de paris
dans sa 12ème salle celle qui serait du
reste la plus vaste du monde devait
durer jusqu en 1874 ont pu cependant
assisté en 1869 à la pause du célèbre
groupe de carpeaux la danse est garni
avait été en mesure d'offrir dès 1867 au
parisien la façade de son monument qui
s'inscrivait dans le cadre des travaux
du baron haussmann
enfin en 1875 la république inaugurait
l'oeuvre de l' empire mais c'est le pari
de 1862 celui qui célèbrait au grand
hôtel en présence de l'impératrice
eugénie la pose de la première pierre de
l'opéra que le pari de 1962 a voulu
faire renaître et à 100 ans de distance
les crinolines ou redessiner les figures
du quadrille sur les airs d'offenbach
[Musique]
on
et route avec eux pour un soir à l'heure
française au casino du liban où le
festival de la chanson française tenait
ses assises et où un jury franco
libanais qui compte et marcel carné
avait à juger 70 chansons et quatorze
interprètes parmi lesquels l'usc en
pleine nuit d'être lourd là si la
voiture se trouvait là si la poussière
de la base était sûrement sûrement mort
il ne voudrait pas partir la voiture et
leur écriture ils s'embrassaient
s'embrasser puis des jeux
témoin
très applaudie lui cela fut aussi celle
que le jury décide à de couronner
doublement du reste puisqu'elle est
l'auteur de la poussière au bois grand
prix de la chanson qui lui valu le prix
d'interprétation féminine
[Musique]
le 13 novembre 61 à bien si twin une
gerbe de feu avaient jailli du puy
crachant vers le ciel plus de 600 tonnes
de poutrelles et de tubes incandescent
qui ont dû dégager à grand peine
restez l'opération principale souffler
la flamme comme celle d'un briquet et
n'avait-on pas nommer la flamme de
gassies twill le briquet du dia
2 800 mètres de profondeur on avait
réussi à mener grâce à des pompes énorme
le stock d'eau nécessaire à la proche de
la flamme
red adair le pompier du pétrole
avait constitué le stock de simone qui
formeraient le bouchon destiné à
s'opposer dans la fuite de gaz malgré
son énorme pression
[Musique]
et voici le jour j après de longues
hésitations red adair est allé dans son
bulldozer blindé faire une dernière
reconnaissance autour de la flamme et
diriger les derniers préparatifs
dans la nuit on a aménagé le fus 240 kg
de dynamite dont l'explosion doit
souffler la torche
au lieu du soleil toute épreuve
[Musique]
l'opération soufflage commence sous les
tonnes d'eau déversées en pluie par les
lances d'incendié la charge de dynamite
à reims au bout d'un bras de fer landes
dit m transporté par un bulldozer
cuirassé d'amiante
[Musique]
soudain c'est l'explosion
camier la flamme brisées par le souffle
ne se rallument pas restait à juguler la
trempe de gaz ce qui a été fait
[Musique]
am seule la couronne de l'impératrice
eugénie la dernière couronne qu'une
femme et eu le privilège de porter en
france avec ses 13 154 brillant ces 11
136 rose et ses 56 émeraude suffirait à
faire voir 36 chandelles et plus à
celles qui viendront se pencher au
louvre sur dix siècles de joaillerie
française de charles le chauve à nos
jours se sont réunis pour un mois des
dizaines et des dizaines de milliards
d'anciens francs de pierres précieuses
et de joyaux au niveau des courants de
royal dont l'une des plus belles et la
couronne de bohème la vedette demeure
parmi les pierres de la couronne de
france le célèbre réjean l'un des plus
précieux diamants du monde 137 carats
que marie l'exarchat porta dans les
cheveux et napoléon aux ponots de l'épée
du ca
on trouvera là également l'évangéliaire
de la sainte-chapelle le sceptre de
charles 5 et compte à côte or et pierres
et l'épée des rois de france et la
couronne de saint lumine
[Musique]
autant de pièces de joaillerie qui
feront rêver sans doute mais qui
témoigneront aussi de la permanence à
paris d'un grand métier de luxe au cours
des siècles
[Musique]
pour le 17ème anniversaire de la
victoire de 1945 le général de gaulle
s'est rendu à l'étoile pour s'incliner
sur la tombe du soldat inconnu les arts
dramatiques qui passe en ce moment sur
le pays font un écho plus profond peut
être cette année à cette cérémonie
anniversaire la victoire de la france
aujourd'hui est ce que ce n'est pas une
victoire sur elle-même dans l'union et
dans la confiance
m
alger en prévision des anniversaires de
mai avait les mesures de sécurité
renforcées dans une ville sans activité
la gendarmerie mobile multiplient les
patrouilles fouillent en méthodiquement
les rares véhicules en circulation
cependant l'interdiction de stationner
dans certaines artères prises pour
lutter contre les voitures piégées a été
appliquée dans toute sa rigueur
160 automobile en défaut ont été jetés à
la décharge publique où leurs
propriétaires sont venus eux-mêmes les
incendier
à marseille plusieurs paquebots déjà
sont arrivés avec à leur bord 300 800 11
cents passagers qui ont quitté l'algérie
des hommes nés en majorité des femmes et
des enfants des musulmans mêler aux
européens
voyages de vacances pour certains mais
pour d'autres ce voyage n'est-il pas
sans retour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour la quinzième fois le cinéma a tenu
ses assises à cannes où le ministre de
l'information monsieur alain peyrefitte
est venu présider la journée de la
presse filmée internationale
[Musique]
à la peine chaque année le cinéma
d'actualité aura donc était aussi à
l'honneur au cours de ce 15ème festival
qui sera le plus long de tous c'est du
reste le prix de la presse filmée qui
devait ouvrir le palmarès
attendons la soupe
[Applaudissements]
pour l'heure la foule une sauce co
vedettes et les cameramen bousculent à
sophia loren et romy schneider leur ont
fourni les premières parmi les plus
réussies sans doute
quant au film 34 sont à la fiche de 4-1
festival chargé
[Musique]
à versailles où l'académie française
s'était transportée en raison des
réparations de la célèbre coupole le
cinéma guidé par marcel achard a été
accueilli de façon très grand siècle
dans l'immortalité l'honorable compagnie
en effet recevez rené clair qu'elle
compte aujourd'hui parmi les siens aux
côtés de daniel rops jean cocteau et
marcel pagnol
à ceux qui animèrent les premiers
tableaux d'une si vaste féerie et qui
sur les mers de mon métier
à ce plan sont les artisans équipe
rennaise thèmes et moi
les déceptions et les enthousiasmes
d'une profession dont la loi et de faire
le mieux possible pour le plus grand
nombre
permettez-moi de dédier une pensée
éternelle au moment où votre compagnie
ben alors arts et lettres de noblesse
c'est en leur nom mes yeux de celui ya
l'honneur de les représenter receipts
aux adresses son remerciement
le suivant la réalisation de son
programme atomique la france a procédé
le 1er mai à une explosion nucléaire
souterraine dans le logar à une centaine
de km au nord de tamanrasset
l'expérience a été conduite dans un
massif granitique au fond d'une galerie
creusée dans la montagne outre son
aspect militaire l'intérêt de ce type
d'essais et de permettre d'envisager des
applications pacifiques des explosifs
nucléaires et d'exclure les risques de
retombées radioactives
et voici l'heure h 3 2 1 0
rendement du sol soulève les poussières
accumulés par l'érosion sans cassure de
la montagne elles ne sont pas
radioactives les émanations son
impermanence contrôler pour déceler tout
danger accidentelle
à l'heure h également d une heure h
retardé depuis quatorze bras les
etats-unis ont lancé à cap canaveral la
première fusée utilisant l'hydrogène
liquide comme carburant monte sur un
premier étage du type atlas cette fusée
nommé senteurs a explosé en vol 50
secondes après son lancement
l'engin aurait dû s'élever à l'altitude
de 500 km et parcourir une distance de
1800 km cet incident amènera peut-être
des retards pour le prochain vol spatial
[Musique]
à l'heure h comment parvenir à ce que
l'alerté soit donnée à temps c'est le
problème qu'ont résolu les ingénieurs
polonais en étant intimement
électronique et chimie un liquide se
répand dans un lit muni du dispositif et
la plaque sensible transmet la peine
c'est là un progrès considérable mais à
qui peut-il servir direz vous mais
honneur survie bien sûr les grands n'ont
pas de ces oublis du jeune âge
[Musique]
sous le ciel le plus bleu du monde
dans le décor le plus chargé d'histoire
hatem a assisté au plus fastueux mariage
de ces dix dernières années la princesse
sophie filles des souverains de graisse
épousait don juan carlos prince des
asturies héritier du trône d'espagne
une première cérémonie religieuse se
déroulait à la cathédrale catholique
devant un parterre de rois et de reines
de princes et de princesses où se
retrouvaient vivants les plus beaux noms
du gotha
dehors la foule grecque à laquelle ce
n'est les 5000 espagnol exprime est une
allégresse toute méditerranéenne en
applaudissant la descente des 141 une
altesse connaissant tous rappelé jean de
luxembourg
bernard de la langue
[Musique]
le comte et la comtesse de paris et leur
fille anne de france
la reine frederica de graisse et le
comte de barcelone mon père d'un joueur
[Applaudissements]
une seconde cérémonie celle là de rite
orthodoxe religion de la famille royale
hélène confirme l union qui allie
aujourd'hui deux dynasties
au bras de son père le roi paul de grèce
la princesse sophie retrouvait don juan
dans la basilique décoré de 30 mille
roses rouges
représentent du primat de grèce assisté
de 24 avec vêtus de brocart se dérouler
les rites sont yeux de la liturgie
orientale reid des couronnes
rip de la danse d'isaïe autour de la
table sacramentelle pluie de pétales
hérite plus familial voici qu'on voit là
même frédéric a lancé au visage des
jeunes mariés deux poignées le pétale
avant de les embrasser
[Musique]
le jeune couple en a concentré sa
carnation au milieu des sonneries de
cloches et des salves d'artillerie et
ses deux jambes visage touchés par les
plats de leur race et de leur élévation
la foule n'en voit plus que l'éclat de
leur bonheur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
atteignent gardera surtout de cette
journée france curieuse le souvenir d'un
sourire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur 16e voyage à travers les provinces
le général de gaulle avait choisi le
quercy et le limousin c'est d'abord
figeac qui l'a accueilli avec cette
chaleur humaine qui est l'une des vertus
de cette vieille province
le général de gaulle devait s'arrêter
ensuite à oradour qui fut en 1944 le
théâtre de l'un des plus sauvages
épisode de la retraite allemand
le monde entier connaît depuis le nom
d'oradour dont les murs ruiné roadies le
drame
[Musique]
à limoges le président largement
applaudi devait reprendre des thèmes
essentiels de la position de la france
l'alliance atlantique at il dit est
nécessaire au monde libre mais dans
cette alliance elle veut être la france
à voir sa volonté sa personnalité son
âme et sa politique elle a d'ailleurs
une tâche pratique à laquelle elle
s'applique cette tâche c'est la
construction de l'europe
[Musique]
transporter la veille au palais de
justice l'ex général salan répond devant
le tribunal militaire de tous les crimes
de l'oas un service d'ordre massif
garder les abords du prétoire où les
reporters n'ont pu apercevoir l'accusé
on ne s'étonnera donc pas de ne voir
dans les couloirs que ses défenseurs au
milieu desquelles m tixier vignancour
on verra à la barre le maréchal de
lattre de tassigny et des témoins
politique monsieur léon delbecque jean
marie le pen françois mitterrand le plus
retentissant
le plus douloureux aussi des procès
d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
bientôt la fête des mères selon une
tradition maintenant établie petits et
grands célébreront cette fête que
magnifier un monument peut être unique
dans tous les foyers la grande
conspiration annuel de la reconnaissance
s'est nouée
[Musique]
et dans la rue même la proche de la fête
des mères a déclenché une vaste
offensive d'affiche et de pavois
[Musique]
oh
c'est l'heure où les tirelires se casse
ou les économies accumulées vont servir
pour le bonheur des uns est aussi le
plaisir des autres c'est l'heure des
cadeaux et quand on voit pas d'avenir
devant soi on a bien le droit d'attendre
même une pluie de millions ceux de la
loterie nationale
dans les écoles on prépare la surprise
cette oeuvre d'art innocent où l'on a
mis son coeur et sa reconnaissance avec
sa joie la fête des mères
[Musique]
le froid n'est pas ce qu'un vin peuple
pense c'est ce qu'une exposition
démontre actuellement à paris grâce au
froid aux foires difficiel 100 ans la
chirurgie a réussi récemment à un
miracle l'opération en hypothermie
profonde coeur et activité cérébrale
arrêter toute vie suspendue les banques
du sang qui ont permis de sauver des
centaines de milliers de vies doivent
leur existence aux techniques du froid
et c'est encore au froid qu'on doit de
pouvoir conserver des organes vivant
pour des greffes d'ultérieures
savait-on seulement que c'est un
français ferdinand carrés qui inventa le
premier appareil à fabriquer de la glace
il ya plus de cent ans déjà et que le
premier bateau frigorifique date de 1876
la glace apportant un progrès
considérable
le poisson passe aujourd'hui de la mer à
la table sans quitter son milieu naturel
l'eau de mer transformée en glace 1
million 500 mille tonnes de denrées
périssables les viandes notamment son
véhicule et chaque année par camion
wagon frigorifique
quant au réfrigérateur que possède
actuellement 4 millions français il est
devenu un ustensile bien banal ce n'est
cependant qu'en 1950 que l'industrie des
réfrigérateurs ménagers a pris son essor
mais avec l allan
une grande usine aéronautique française
amener son expérience au service de ce
froid domestique éléments de luxe hier
devenu indispensable aujourd'hui c'est
la nuit écrivait rostand qu'il est bon
de croire à la lumière mais ce n'est pas
seulement l'été qu'on peut apprécier le
froid c'est chaque jour
[Musique]
deux parachutistes sur la région de
haguenau en alsace et manoeuvre bien sûr
mais qui ont réuni l'ancien chef départ
allemand en crète le général crowe est
un ancien de la 2e db le général massu
pour la première fois les parachutistes
français et allemands participé côte à
côte à un exercice aéroportée mille
paras français béret rouge et six ans
par allemand casquette grise avec armes
et matériels ont été ainsi largué en
simple avec l'appui des escargots de
l'armée de l'air française et de la
luftwaffe un événement dans l'histoire
mouvementée des deux pays
jules et ça pendant ce temps on
procédait aux démonstrations
spectaculaires d'un nouveau siège
éjectable pour pilote d'appareil
supersonique on a pu constater par la
même occasion que le fantassin avait
également fait de grands progrès
désormais grâce à un réacteur individuel
il pourra agrémenter sa marche
traditionnelle de quelques dons dans
l'atmosphère
or on fantasme américain
[Applaudissements]
dans cet autre entre deux nouveautés
l'industrie automobile vient de
présenter à montlhéry deux modèles de
plus le spécial et le b7000 et
journalistes spécialisés ont été conviée
à apprécier les qualités en toute
connaissance de cause c'est à dire en en
faisant tout de même l'expérience
du spécial ses qualités de silence grâce
à une abbatiale au textile nouveau et
son confort du précepte son confort et
son silence également mais surtout sa
réserve d'adhérence dans tous les cas
difficiles virages et freinage
[Musique]
et non des accidents n'est que trop
inquiétant aujourd'hui pourquoi ne
suis-je pas avec intérêt tout d'abord
nouveau dans la sécurité
à
dans une gare de tokyo s'est déroulée
l'un des drames les plus effroyables de
l'histoire ferroviaire le déraillement
d'un premier train a entraîné la
collision de deux autres convois un
fantastique amoncellement d'acier tordus
de wagons entremêlés de corps
déchiquetés c'est le spectacle
hallucinant devant lequel se sont
trouvées les secours
163 morts et 385 blessés grièvement pour
la plupart ces chiffres situe l'ampleur
de la tragédie
[Musique]
la reconnaissance des victimes a donné
lieu à des scènes particulièrement
dramatiques devant la file des cercueils
une foule en larmes cherche à retrouver
un être cher
des filets à la fois misérables est
stupéfiant que le reporter a saisi avec
l'impassibilité du métier mais qui donne
à chacun le goût vrai et si affreusement
humain du g
[Musique]
après neuf mois de football insipide le
championnat de france est terminée par
un sprint excitant de 90 minutes une
heure et demie avant la fin du
championnat trois équipes ont abordé
presque au coude à coude le dernier
match nîmes légèrement détaché avec un
tout petit point d'avancé suivi de reims
et du racing club de paris botte à botte
des millions de français ont suivi avec
passion cette ultime spectacle suspense
il aurait voulu être partout à la fois
la radio et l ajustement et elle était
partout à la fois
à monaco 15h29 le racing maillot clair
qu'ils le croient prend une option sur
le titre en marquant son premier but
pendant ce temps que se passe-t-il à
reims toujours 0 0 devant strasbourg mes
copains numéro 9 pouces à fond ses
partenaires
[Applaudissements]
une passe à sauvage qui marque reims
revient à la hauteur du reste
kopa et ses partenaires ne s'arrête pas
en si bon chemin il faut à tout prix
prince marque encore d'autres bus pour
être le champion de france ça ne va pas
tarder nouvel exploit de sauvages reims
prend la tête du peloton encore 45
minutes à savoir qui sera champion de
france et on parle d pas ce que font les
nîmois devant le stade français pas
grand chose de bon le score n'a pas
changé depuis le début du match les
nîmois un maillot foncé sont paralysé
par le trac
le titre leur échappe à 7 minutes
précises qui bat l'avant centre du stade
français n'a qu'un but qui brochet
lépine éponyme c'est d'ailleurs fini
également pour le racing puisque à reims
les bus succède au but
[Applaudissements]
là encore quand alan ses partenaires qui
vont pas tarder a ajouté un quatrième
but au tableau d'affichage
des mines le championnat avec beaucoup
d'élégance et c'est akesbi qui signe le
dernier but des rémois
[Applaudissements]
les rémois qui sont donc sans confiance
mais regrettons que reims est attendu la
dernière journée du championnat pour
prouver ses qualités
[Applaudissements]
à
dans un palais de justice ou issus
sévèrement gardée le procès de l'ex
général salan a pris fin sur un verdict
qui a exclu la peine de mort notre
reporter n'a pu filmer que l'atmosphère
des couloirs au tour du défenseur de
l'inculpé m tixier vignancour satisfait
mais rompu par trois heures de
plaidoiries et l'émotion de voir sauver
la tête de son client
ce verdict a causé dans les esprits une
agitation dont les journaux de toutes
les opinions se sont fait l'écho quelles
répercussions aura demain cette décision
de justice nouveau problème qui s'ajoute
à tous ceux qui ont course entre
l'algérie le plus urgent est celui des
réfugiés le hall de l'aéroport de maison
blanche et jour et nuit l'asile de
centaines de familles en partance pour
lesquels un pont aérien a été établi
chaque jour maintenant une dizaine
d'avions de ligne ou la rotation alger
marseille déversant à marignane leur
cargaison doit ya jeunes la peur du
lendemain l' angoisse du présent donne à
cet exode ces raisons et ses réseaux
noces sont ils ces migrants une minorité
bientôt absorbé sont-ils l'avant garde
d'un retour plus massif
en mettant à leur disposition un bloc
d'immeubles en construction dans la
banlieue de marseille le gouvernement
s'est appliqué à parer au plus pressé
avant de prendre les mesures
d'adaptation et de reclassement qui
s'impose déjà l'amorcé de ce
reclassement peut s'apercevoir en
camargue une propriété de 40 hectares a
recueilli le bachaga boualem sa famille
et ses familiers 66 personnes en tout
menacés sur leur sol ils ont choisi
l'exil peut-être ici le seigneur de
loire se lisait ses fidèles dont il
refaire leur patrie
[Musique]
e
le chapeau s'est mis à la mode de
bretagne
il n'est plus possible de l'éviter nous
élégante auront cette saison des
chapeaux ronds
transformable ou simplement déformable
inéluctablement rond inéluctablement
petit breton ce couvre chef admet
cependant chez jean barthet des
interprétations diverses c'est ainsi que
le bob ne ferait pas et s'adjoint en
toute modestie une rose géante que le
hall on pend fait généralement très bon
ménage avec le petit breton classique
mais petit breton il y en a du reste
pour tous les goûts et pour toutes les
personnalités il y en a deux sages de
réserve et il y en a aussi de délurée
le bob se voient souvent assorties des
efflorescences printanière et se prête
aux interprétations psychologiques de
leur bref dans sa variété la mode du
chapeau rond plaît mais qu'on s'en rend
compte que d'aller observer le rayon des
chapeaux d'un grand magasin parisien où
jean barthet a ouvert son rayon les pubs
et les petits bretons on se les arrache
positivement
telle est la force de cette nouvelle
mode
[Musique]
mais le long des chapeaux ronds comme
dit à peu près la chanson if demandé
breton
[Musique]
président de la toute jeune république
islamique de mauritanie monsieur moktar
ould daddah rendant visite à la france a
été accueilli à son arrivée par le
général de gaulle
la république islamique de mauritanie
qui est l'un des états africains à qui
la france a donné l'indépendance a on le
sait une place de choix dans le contexte
international
ce qui impose une importance
particulière aux entretiens qui ont
réuni à l'elysée les deux interlocuteurs
le geste traditionnel de l'étoile à
donner son sens à cette visite le
président mokhtar ould daddah n'at-il
pas dit à son arrivée la mauritanie a
fait une longue route commune avec la
france qui a accompli dans notre pays
une oeuvre dont elle peut être fière
un an de plus pour le festival de cannes
sophie des marais la seule femme du jury
et le ministre de l'information monsieur
alain peyrefitte ont clôturé cette
quinzième épreuve de fond qui a vu et
demi je payais remettre la palme d'or à
anselmo duarte le réalisateur du film
brésilien la parole donnée
restait très ouverte jusqu'au bout et
c'est sans doute pourquoi le prix
spécial du jury a été décerné ex-aequo à
l'italien antonio ni pour l'équipe et
aux français robert bresson que
représentait le directeur du cinéma
monsieur fourré cormerais pour le procès
de jeanne mas 21 jours et 20 nuits le
festival et à l'an prochain
[Musique]
le twist encore le pis on croyait
l'épidémie en voie de régression elle
continue de se propager et bien non pas
de signaler à berlin un concours de
twist qui prouve que dans l'ex capitale
allemande la maladie est en pleine
évolution
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les caméramen eux-mêmes ne semble pas
avoir échappé au virus faudra-t-il
envisager une conférence au sommet
[Musique]
l'amérique a vécu sa deuxième journée de
l'espace il est 4 heures 40 à cap
canaveral un gentleman en combinaison
argentée sa petite valise à la main
prend l'ascenseur du cosmos à la 11è
passerelle l'attend la capsule mercury
aurore septe scott carpenteyre va
rééditer l'exploit de glen trois tours
de la terre un événement banal en somme
et pourtant journalistes cameramen et à
travers l'amérique et le monde sont
saisi par l'émotion quand le jour paraît
et que sans l'être pesant la fusée atlas
la première fois un télescope permettra
de suivre le moment crucial de la
séparation de la capsule et de la fusée
lors de la mise sur orbite
elle est finie
maintenant comme il ne fera trois fois
40e prague autour de la terre
sa voix précise que tout va bien à bord
ni tels que jean nuit du à la
température
[Musique]
et c'est la fin du troisième tour
ralenti par ces lettres aux fusées la
capsule rentrer dans l'atmosphère on va
perdre le contact radio quelques minutes
mais la circonstance est prévu
cette fois pourtant le silence se
prolonge il se fait pesant il semble que
la main d'oeuvre n'est pas été parfaite
et le fait est que la capsule touchera
l'océan à 300 kilomètres du point prévu
le suspense dura 54 minutes finalement
on apprendra enfin que des plongeurs
parachutistes ont été largués au dessus
du point de chute un avion a dit le
communiqué officiel a repéré la cabine
et à côté un radeau de sauvetage quand
un gentleman qui al'air confortablement
installés confortablement semble
d'ailleurs superflu l'amérique respire
scott carpenter a accompli sa mission
[Musique]
trente millions de recettes et 40000
spectateurs à toulouse pour la finale de
championnat de france de rugby entre
agen maillot blanc et la hesse béziers
jeu rude des biterrois qui veulent se
faire respecter résultat un coup franc
qui leur coûtent trois points dès le
début du match
cela n'empêche pas béziers équipe
complète et bien équilibré sous la
conduite de son maître à jouer pierre
danos de prendre l'ascendant sur agen au
cours de la première mi-temps ascendant
qui se traduit par ce très bel essai sur
mêlée tournée que mal en même temps les
huit avants biterrois essai transformé
auxquels s'ajoutent quelques instants
plus tard un but de pénalité béziers
mène donc 1 8 à 3 lorsque débute la
deuxième mi temps et sans plus attendre
de dieux marquent un drop 11 à 3 le
match paraît gagner pour béziers et
c'est là que le miracle se produit ce
miracle il est caractérisé par cette
attaque des agenais qui étouffent leurs
adversaires la descente est arrêtée qu'à
cela ne tienne elle repart de l'autre
côté avec tous les trois quarts qui
ponctue par un essai de mérite
il en sera ainsi tout au long de la
deuxième mi-temps baissier qui perd
toutes les vannes à la touche n'a plus
qu'une solution défendre défendre à tout
prix son avantage et les attaques ne
s'arrête jamais merrick bouclé recentre
au pied l'un de ses avants a suivi ça y
est 11 à 9 on est maintenant quasi
certain que les agenais vont gagner
d'autant qu'il ne ralentissent pas le
rythme merrimack un nouvel essai
transformé 14 à 11 agen champion de
france
m
[Musique]